long long time ago my English so bad in
that time you're right highness yes yes
yeah and then I have to remember your
Royal Highness your right highness
Dennis well we've been playing around oh
Queen's coming please come in here
what should I say then I see the queen
stop stop stop so quick I said oh okay
then when she comes you're right but
middle is bow
too loud she's stands still standing
there the people
oh
she keep talking to me
my head is empty I don't know what
you're talking about
of course I'm so happy just standing
here more than like a three minute five
minute but I just don't go away please
don't talk to me anymore I don't know
how to answer back